zu deutsch spricht 2009 10
heute ist sehr grün abschluss unserer
mehrwöchigen aktion deutschland spricht
das findet statt in der frauenkirche in
dresden und eben in der paulskirche in
frankfurt am main
und hier treffen sich heute nachmittag
schon bestimmt einige hundert paare von
menschen die miteinander kontrovers über
fragen diskutieren wollen wie es mit
deutschland in der zukunft weitergehen
soll
[Musik]
eine idee war wir bauen so eine art
dating plattform für politische
gegensätze ein tender für politik so so
stand das einmal und daraus ist dann
tatsächlich am ende deutschland sprich
geworden also eine kleine plattform es
war sehr witzig die es aber geschafft
hat so zu sagen leute mit
unterschiedlichen politischen meinungen
tatsächlich im realen leben zu einem
eins zu eins gespräch zu verabreden
ich mache heute mit weil ich diese frage
sieben fragen schwarz-weiß sehr
polarisierend ich mache hier mit weil
ich mich für andere meinungen generell
interessiert weil ich glaube ein offener
mensch zu sein ich mache ja heute mit
weil ich aktiv am politischen diskurs
teilnehmen wollte nach den vorkommnissen
den wahlen und halle und lücke und ich
finde
entwickelt sich zentrifugalkräfte und
ich finde man muss alles was die
demokratische mitte ist stark ich liebe
es nicht selbst infrage gestellt zu
werden aber umso herausfordernder finde
ich es genau diese gelegenheit heute
einmal zu nutzen
also sind 13.000 bis 14.000 leute und
letztendlich so bis zum schluss dabei
geblieben und aus dieser grundgesamtheit
dann haben sich matches ergeben also
paarungen gesprächs paare die eine
einladung bekommen haben nach frankfurt
zu kommen nach dresden zu kommen und
sicherheit am heutigen tage zu treffen
zu einem gespräch natürlich als
ansatzpunkt sind diese sieben fragen die
bei uns auch in den artikeln wir drinnen
hängen klimawandel kümmern sich die
westdeutschen jugend oft deutschen wir
sehen an den ergebnissen der ersten
umfrage dass deutschland da geteiltes
und ost und west geteilt ist das heißt
genauso viele westdeutsche wie aus
deutsche die finden ja wir kümmern uns
richtig und es gibt genauso wie
westdeutsche wie auch deutsche die sagen
wir kümmern uns zu wenig
[Musik]
unsere gesellschaft falle zunehmend
auseinander wird gelegentlich geklagt
sie polarisieren sich das meinungsklima
werde rauer der ton 0 zahmer dem ist
schwer zu widersprechen und es liegt
nicht nur an den pöbeleien in den
digitalen netz und netzwerken
das ist nicht schön aber es ist nach
meiner überzeugung nicht die mutter
aller probleme wenn es um etwas geht
darf und soll gestritten werden dass die
fetzen fliegen letzten jahr weihnachten
saßen wir das in der familie zusammen
und es dauerte nicht lange da fing es an
mit einer diskussion zunächst zwischen
meiner nichte und mir über soziale
gerechtigkeit über inklusion und über
andere themen
bald war auch die ganze großfamilie
beteiligt und wir haben uns sehr lebhaft
auseinandergesetzt haben sogar
gestritten es wurde laut bist meine
mutter lang mit der autorität die a 96
jahre sagte so das muss jetzt
weihnachten wirklich nicht sein
aber ich glaube wir alle vielleicht
außer meiner mutter haben dieses
weihnachtsfest in bester erinnerung weil
wir das gefühl hatten ja es geht uns bei
den themen um etwas wir sind
unterschiedliche auffassungen
die haben aber ausgetauscht die
unterschiedlichen meinungen und wir
haben einander zugehört und das finde
ich wichtig